in 1923's the ten commandments the
israelites walk through the parted red
sea it's actually two separate shots
combined into one according to sources
at the time the first shot was just the
actors and the second was actually
gelatin
this compositing technique was a
precursor to the blue and green screen
technology that has taken over the
industry there's almost nothing that is
completely unrelated to a previous
effect back before the widespread use of
cgi effects artists and filmmakers did
everything from painting on top of shots
to projecting moving backgrounds to make
the impossible happen
here are seven tricks used in old
hollywood that still exist in some form
today
cg allows filmmakers to place people and
objects anywhere they want in a scene
but it wasn't used in a movie until
1973's west world so how did filmmakers
in the early 1900s do this
with arguably the first ever special
effect the substitution splice
a filmmaker would start filming a scene
then they'd stop the camera and start
shooting again from the same position
with a new person or object added to the
frame this effect made it seem like
something or someone appeared out of
thin air
director georges melies used a
substitution splice in many of his
on-screen illusions such as this one in
1896's the vanishing lady the trick was
also used to pull off dangerous stunts
take a look at 1895's the execution of
mary queen of scots to make the
monarch's beheading look real the actor
first knelt at the chopping block then
the director stopped filming and a dummy
was placed where the actor was when they
resumed filming the executioner chopped
off the dummy's head by today's
standards this early form of editing is
pretty noticeable
stunt coordinators these days improve
this concept with camera lock-offs take
this moment when the rock's character
gets hit in the face by a motorcycle in
2016's central intelligence to keep the
actor safe they filmed the shot from the
exact same angle twice first they
captured a motorcyclist doing a backflip
then the rock stunt double being pulled
back with today's visual effects
technology the two takes could be
seamlessly combined
one of the earliest challenges of
animation was natural movement so
animators turned to rotoscoping first
thought up by max and dave fleischer
artists would project live-action film
footage onto their easel and sketch over
the images frame by frame so they could
mimic real-life movements for example in
the 1932 cartoon mini the moocher the
fleischer brothers gave the characters
eye-popping dance moves by rotoscoping
cab callaway nowadays rotoscoping
software allows for this process to be
used on something much longer than a
short cartoon like the tv series undone
and motion capture tech is a natural
extension of the fleischer's work with
fully realized mocap characters like
thanos in infinity war
1933's the invisible man needed to shoot
its invisible lead wearing clothes so
the audience could see him how do you
create a floating shirt without today's
technology
instead of a green screen they used a
technique called compositing in melies
time this could be done through double
exposure but james whale instead used a
compositing method known as the williams
process
first after claude reigns was filmed in
black velvet against a black backdrop
this created a negative allowing every
part of the actor to disappear except
for the parts not covered in black they
then filmed the background separately
these maths were then printed masking
off the foreground and background until
the two images were combined
creating the right composite images
often involved thinking outside the box
like that scene from the ten
commandments we described earlier
because the compositing was done by hand
it was an imperfect process if you watch
old movies in which you can see the
edges around the figures where they've
been composited in that means that the
optical printer operator was short on
time oftentimes it's just chief effects
because they didn't want to spend money
to do it modern compositing is much
smoother the black screen used in 1933's
invisible man has been replaced with
today's blue and green screens and
elements are filmed on motion control
cameras for a more seamless composite
like in 2020 is the invisible man they
first shot one take of elizabeth moss
being attacked by a stand-in and then a
second clean take without them
things get a bit more complicated when
it comes to fantasy backgrounds like in
the wizard of oz the filmmakers couldn't
just composite in real footage for the
land of oz and building all the sets
from scratch would have been a difficult
task
so instead they used matte paintings to
paint around the characters
for this effect a map blocking
everything except the actors was placed
in front of the camera the artists later
painted the surroundings on a separate
glass mat before the two images were
combined so for example when dorothy
walks down the yellow brick road in this
shot it was actually just the actors on
a set with no backdrop the sky flowers
and mountains were all painted in after
the fact to make it look like they were
headed towards the emerald city but it's
still hard to overcome the flatness of a
painting look at this shot of orson
welles speaking in front of a large
crowd in citizen kane the painted extras
appear completely lifeless
present day digital mats and set
extensions offer a fix to that by
duplicating tiles of real extras and
adding digital doubles into the mix ted
lasso could create a fully formed
stadium filled with 26 000 fans who
could react directly to the action shot
in camera
without today's animation software it
can be difficult to add realistic
three-dimensional depth to hand-drawn
scenes so in the 1930s and 40s many
animated disney classics used an
invention called a multi-plane camera
the camera was attached to several
layers of glass each displaying a
different layer of artwork each layer
could be moved at different speeds and
distances from each other
because the two-dimensional drawings
were separated in real three-dimensional
space they created a parallax effect
this camera helped add depth to the
forest and bambi and it's how filmmakers
made the evil queen surrounding spin
around her in snow white in the seven
dwarfs
these days the multi-plane camera effect
is recreated digitally the various
layers can be designed and easily
separated on a computer to create the
illusion of depth and filmmakers are
getting more creative with how they
integrate 3d assets and trick the eye
2020s wolf walkers created a 3d forest
as a guide to place hand-drawn
characters into dynamic environments
even before cg filmmakers tried to fix
the static nature of painted mats and 2d
backgrounds one solution was rear
projection which created dynamic moving
backgrounds in real time an actor would
stand in front of a screen and behind
that screen a projector would play
footage shot elsewhere
like this shot from 1938's bringing up
baby in reality the two stars on this
leopard were nowhere near each other
harry grant and catherine hepburn were
actually driving in a fake car on a set
while the leopard was shot separately
and projected behind them on a screen
for this plane crash from 1940s foreign
correspondent director alfred hitchcock
projected real footage of the sky and
ocean through the cockpit's windows
but rear projection had its own issues
because it was projected from the back
the lighting and image looked a lot less
realistic plus it was difficult to match
the lighting of the real world in the
studio
that's why the background roads in these
driving scenes from to catch a thief and
dr no look so flat today
rear projection also became harder to
utilize as more and more films were shot
in color
colors are often just a little off and
they're just off enough that especially
today because you know with digital
composites you can correct that stuff
pretty easily but you couldn't at the
time still rear projection lives on
through boundary pushing technologies
used by directors like stanley kubrick
and john favreau
in 2001 a space odyssey kubrick instead
placed the projector in front of the
screen with the light bouncing off a
mirror this created a stunning deep
focus and perspective during the dawn of
man sequence you won't see that in a
rear projection or any map painting and
led screens have turned projection from
a cheesy effect to awe-inspiring
for example the mandalorian chose to
swap projections and green screens with
led screens you can immediately see how
naturally the light reflects off the
mandalorian and baby yoda in this shot
and because the camera actually moves in
sync with the background this shot has a
natural parallax effect just like those
multiplane cameras from decades earlier
before monsters and other creatures
could be created with cg and motion
capture filmmakers primarily used stop
motion animation but stop motion
requires expensive miniature models and
sets which often look unnatural when
interacting with the cast you can see
that from looking at king kong as the
claymation kong can't truly interact
with fey ray
so pioneering stop-motion animator ray
harryhausen thought of dynamation
his method combined a range of visual
effects techniques from maths to
projection
to understand how it works let's look at
this fight scene between human
characters and a skeleton army in 1963's
jason and the argonauts the actors
rehearsed their moves with stunt people
who stood in for the skeleton army but
the scene was actually shot without the
stunt performers and only with the
actors playing the human characters
erihausen then used stop motion for the
skeleton army to match the movements
perfectly the footage of the actor's
shadow boxing was projected behind the
animation table while harryhausen moved
the skeletons frame by frame a camera
filmed the skeleton army through a glass
mat masking off the shadow boxing actors
finally the shadow boxing scene and the
skeleton scenes were printed and
composited together this five-minute
sequence took four and a half months to
complete but dynamation's influence can
still be seen in the blue and green suit
performers standing in for characters
that will be created with cg in 2019's
dumbo a green suit performer helped the
cast with their sight lines when
interacting with the baby elephant and
motion capture allows an actor to play a
cg dog on set so nobody is guessing
where they have to look
looking back at dynamation's individual
elements each effect can seem
time-consuming and outdated on its own
but it shows how every technological
advancement in cinema wouldn't exist
without the low-tech experiments of the
industry's past
[Music]
you